- Hello, everyone. Hi,
thank you for coming.
My name is Ron, I'm the
co-founder and CTO of Eon.
And with me, I have CJ.
- Hi, CJ Keefe.
I'm the Director of
Infrastructure, DevOps, and SRE
for SoFi.
- Great, so today, we're gonna talk
about cloud infrastructure backup,
and I think that it's gonna
be a different point of view
on what backups can really do for you.
So I'll start
and then CJ will tell us
how SoFi leveraged Eon
to get more out of their backups.
So let's start by just
letting you know what Eon is.
So Eon is a cloud
infrastructure backup company.
We've founded the company two years ago,
and Eon is one of the most
fastest growing companies
in that space of cloud infrastructure
and cybersecurity ever.
And that might sound a bit surprising,
how can something as mundane as backup
can drive such hypergrowth?
And I think that this is going
to be very interesting today
because our mission
is to unlock the true potential of backups
and the true potential of backups,
which until today were kind
of useless insurance policies
in some way
that we really had to store.
We had to have backups for everything
because we might need to
recover data, obviously,
but compliance also mandates that.
But we didn't get a lot
of value out of that.
And cloud infrastructure backups
accrue between 10 and 30%
of your cloud bill.
So that didn't make sense for us.
We said how can we have
so much spend in the cloud
that doesn't generate enough value?
And not surprisingly,
everything starts with the AI
and with these unbelievable
advancements that we've seen
over the past years
and this technology that
actually changes every aspect
of our lives these days.
And when we have such a
disruptive technology,
it always introduces
opportunity, obviously,
but also confusion,
noise, fear, et cetera.
So what does backup have to do with AI?
That is something
which is not as intuitive
as we would think.
And let's say, what?
So if we would look at AI,
and what AI basically means today
is that it requires, as
all new technologies,
infrastructure and applications.
So we have great applications
that leverage AI today, so many,
and we have these amazing things,
those foundational models, those
LLMs that use generative AI
and bring so much value to organizations.
And then the classic infrastructure,
compute, obviously, databases, and so on.
And then there's something very unique
and interesting with AI.
It's data.
Basically, AI takes data
and makes it the enterprise's
invaluable asset.
So almost your currency.
So in a space where data is so precious
and is such an asset,
that basically means that
we need access to our data
and we need our data.
So let's imagine that
we could go back in time
and talk to ourselves
a couple of years back
and tell them that this is
what is going to happen.
Your data is going to be
your most valuable asset
and obviously, we would
start to store the data,
hold the data and leverage that.
But that's really interesting
because if you look at your data today,
you actually do have that data,
that historical data in your backups.
But your backed up data
today is pretty much useless
because you can't read the data,
you can't access the data,
so you can't leverage it for AI.
And that's where Eon transformed
this market completely
and that's what drove this
hypergrowth that we've had
in customer adoption.
So we'll talk about that,
but before we talk about that,
let's just tell,
well, what is backup
actually in the cloud?
Because we were used to,
for someone like me that have
been operating in that space
for close to 20 years,
backups were tapes or boxes
that we put in data centers
and took snapshots of whatever
you had in your data center.
But in the cloud,
backups basically are in the
form of either versioning
and replication of object storage
and the storage services
or cloud native snapshots.
Your databases, managed or unmanaged,
SQL database, relational
databases are now SQL
like your DynamoDB, et cetera.
And these are the actual forms of backup,
but all of them stored on S3,
if we're talking about AWS.
But you can't access the data,
if I have an RDS snapshot or
an EBS snapshot, for example,
and I want to access the
data that is backed up
in that RDS snapshot,
I need to do a full-blown restoration
into a different location,
and only then can I access the data
and we'll talk about why
is that so challenging
and why doesn't it make any sense
for you to pay such a huge
chunk of your cloud bill
and for storage that you
pay per gig per month
but can't access the data.
So we'll talk about how Eon
completely transforms that.
But before we do that,
and we'll obviously see
how SoFi leveraged that
with Eon as well,
but before we do that,
let's start with the problem description.
Why are backups broken in the cloud today?
What are the challenges
that we have been seeing
customers face in that space?
And we've seen that over the years.
Before co-founding Eon,
I was the general manager
for the migration disaster
recovery services at AWS.
And we've seen from up close
why customers are struggling
with their cloud infrastructure backup,
both in managing it,
orchestrating backups,
but primarily when they do need access
to that backed-up storage,
what can they do
and why is it so hard?
So there's very limited visibility.
We've seen advancements in
the space of cloud security
and performance monitoring and so on
that didn't apply for backups.
It's very hard to manage backup policies
to know if you're backing
up what you actually need
for the right amount of
time in the right locations
and are you paying for
what you actually need
or are you exposing yourself to risk
if you have friction
when you need to pass a compliance audit
and you need to prove that
you're backing up data,
how can you access the data,
how can you show that
you're backing up your data
as you should have,
both on the reporting side
but also with generating evidence?
The process today of generating evidence
that you're backing up your data properly
requires you to do a
full-blown restoration
of the entire thing.
Think of a large DynamoDB table
with billions of items.
In order to access one backed up item,
you need to recover the
entire billions of them,
pay a lot of money on
creating a huge table
only to access that single
record that you need
for your compliance audit.
That doesn't make any sense.
And basically, it means that
your data is inaccessible.
So what we've started with that problem,
let's solve the problem of recovery.
Because on the other hand,
there was another space
that did amazing advancements
over the past few years
and that's the data management space
where companies like
Databricks and Snowflakes
and the cloud providers
have done amazing job
in storing data in data lakes
in a format that is readable
that can be used by any
engine such as Athena in AWS.
And our thought was, let's take backup
and use that piece of
technology, use that format
in order to store the backed-up data,
which is still immutable, still
object block, still air gap.
So it's a full-blown read-only backup
across points in time,
but it is accessible.
So I can run SQL queries
directly on top of my backup
and I will show you that in the demo
and while we are accessing the data
for the purposes of recovery,
that basically allows us to use it for AI,
for analytics, for a lot of other things.
And that data that we've been storing
for that period of time
is now a valuable asset.
And that can be a huge win for all of us.
And then there's cost,
and cost is rising,
when we look at cloud
infrastructure backup,
it's extremely ineffective
in the way that it is stored.
And the reason,
and we'll talk about that in depth today,
is that the technology that
is used to storing backups,
which is basically incremental storage,
every day, your data changes,
some percentage of it
changes, not all of it.
So we need to store every
day only what have changed,
those deltas.
But that's a very, very
complex thing to do.
And all of the technology was
invented for data centers.
All of the vendors out there
that are doing cloud infrastructure backup
took their technology from on-prem
and tried to apply to the cloud.
But the cloud is different.
It's different
because storing data in the object storage
is not bound to a single disc.
It is scalable
and APIs cost money
because it's a distributed control plane.
So reading and writing
when you're doing that incremental changes
and deduplication algorithms
accrue a lot of cost of APIs
and that's what we've
solved with Eon as well.
And then there is a ransomware risk
in data protection.
And we are seeing today
that there's a huge gap
in ransomware detection
specifically in the cloud.
And definitely, when we're
referring to managed databases
that can be encrypted
in the application layer
and we'll see how we
unsolved that as well.
So a little bit about Eon.
First of all, as I've said,
Eon provides live data access to backups.
And that's extremely
important for various reasons.
First of all, as we've said,
simplify the recovery piece.
When I need to recover data,
I don't want that old operating system,
which is coupled with the data.
Let's say that I wanna
run a simple SQL query
on a snapshot from a year ago.
Today, before Eon, I would have,
and let's assume that that was running
on a Postgres database on a VM, on an EC2,
I would have to recover
the entire EC2 instance.
Now think about it, it
brings old operating system,
a year old, packed with
security vulnerabilities.
It'll pull from the past
that old Postgres software,
which is potentially end of life,
and the DBA to upgrade it.
It needs to live in a network
that potentially does not exist anymore,
and it consumes resources and accrue cost.
It needs to run full-blown compute.
I only wanna run fetch one record
and I need to restore
potentially terabytes of data.
With Eon, we provide
live access to the backup
and we'll show you how,
we wanna reduce the
total cost of ownership,
and that ties back to AI.
AI accrues a lot of cost for compute.
If there are inefficiencies
in the way that you're
storing your backups
and you're spending such a
large chunk of your cloud bill
on that,
we wanna free up that budget
either for you to be more efficient
or to move that to things
that bring you value
and to use that once again for AI.
Eon does full ransomware
resilience for all of the services,
including managed and unmanaged databases,
VMs, file services,
and I'll show you how
and just doing automation
around backup management.
So how can I access my
data from my backups?
We've just said that the backup
is holding all of the data
and the historical data as well,
and I want to leverage that
in order to gain all of that value.
So Eon transforms your cloud backup
to a live data lake.
So if you would look at the
bottom section of this slide,
you'll see that Eon,
you know, even before we go into backups,
what is a data lake?
So a data lake basically is a lot of data
that is stored on object storage,
usually, let's say on S3,
in a format which is readable,
Avro or Parquet files are the
most popular file formats.
But in order to ingest
data into the data lake,
you need to extract it
from all of the different
cloud resources, your ETLs.
And that is extremely disruptive,
especially for enterprises,
'cause think about it,
you need to access each
production database.
You need to know what's in there
and you need to build
an engineering project
that actually fetches the data.
Eon has a different approach.
We're backing up the data anyway,
so we're accessing the data anyway
without accessing the production,
without impacting the production.
But when we're backing up the data,
we're extracting the Tableau data,
the data from databases, file systems,
indexing them completely,
and then storing them in object storage,
whatever cloud that you choose.
So now you had the zero-ETL data lake,
data from all of your
backups is transformed,
including converting your old
snapshots into that layer.
And then once you have all of the data
stored in a more efficient way,
you'll see cost cut down by at least 50%.
And now you can leverage
that data as well.
And we expose it via public interfaces.
So beyond Eon's API,
you can just access it using
simple object storage APIs
and we also add catalogs around it.
So the next piece of data lake
is trying to understand
what do I have in that data.
Now it helps me to recover data
because now if a
compliance auditor asked me
to provide the evidence
of this and that data,
I can just easily do that,
'cause everything is indexed,
searchable, queryable.
But I can also use analytics
and data lakes tools
on top of my backups.
So things like Amazon Redshift and Glue,
Snowflake, Databricks.
Every analytics engine that
supports data lake format
can now be directed directly
on top of your backups.
And now let's talk about AI.
So we've already got that place
where we can extract all of your data
from all of your resources
converted into readable format
that is accessible to
those analytics engine
because a data backup platform
needs to process all of your data,
100% of your data because it back it up.
So every byte that changes,
every row in a database that is updated
needs to be backed up.
We can do light calculations
that doesn't add any
significant cost at all
in the backup process.
So once we're backing up the data,
we are indexing the data that
is backed up in a few ways.
The first is trying to
understand what's in my data.
When I'm backing up a
database, for example,
I will use a foundational model,
an LLM that is owned by the customer.
So we can support any LLM
that the customer decides to bring.
So for example, let's take
Claude via Bedrock as an example,
and it generates some textual context
on what does that table has
for each and every database
table that we're backing up,
we're taking that data
and we're embedding it
in a vector database.
And that allows us to do
RAG on top of the backup.
We'll see that in action in a minute.
But what it actually means
that now I can search across my backup
and I can find the data that I'm after
across all of my backups.
On top of that,
we're doing some calculations
such as entropy calculation,
which is the primary tool
to identify ransomware.
And we're doing some algorithms
that identify lineage
between the different resources.
So what can be joinable with what,
how can I join data from
one resource to another,
that is extremely valuable,
and we'll see that.
So all of that brings a lot of value.
And then on the client side,
we have a chat interface that
allows us to search for data,
to generate queries
that can run on my data
in order to simplify recovery
and also gain a lot of insight,
from my data, generate reports,
doing analytics and so on.
So cross-cloud resilience
is the next topic,
and we'll see that in action in a minute.
We've all seen outages
recently in all cloud providers
and when there's an outage,
it's a very interesting phenomena.
And being there as the GM for
the disaster carbon services
back in '21 when we've
seen similar events,
we've seen that customers
are very reluctant
to actually fail over.
And the reason
is because failing over
from one region to another
is, first of all, it's a hard problem.
It's a hard problem to solve,
and it adds a lot of risk.
And you're starting with that race.
Who will recover first?
Will I succeed to recover
first to a different region
or will the cloud provider
recover before I should even try?
And we've seen customers, first
of all, sitting and waiting
and throughout the time
before they're failing over,
they're losing access to their data
because their backups
once again are locked.
They can't read data from their backups.
So now they're downtime
in their primary region
and they can't access
their data in the secondary
until they will do that
full-blown recovery.
More than that if outages take too long,
like we've seen, right now, 14 hours,
customers do try, give
up and try to fail over.
And then there is a very
interesting phenomena,
there are not enough
resources in the target region
to hold all of that load.
So something like us-east-1,
which is such a popular region,
trying to fail over to a different region
and customers are getting iced,
insufficient capacity error,
which basically means that
they can't run compute
in that region.
And today, data is
coupled with that compute.
If I have an RDS snapshot,
once again, I'll need a VM,
an RDS instance that has an
issue to instance under the hood
in order to access the data.
But with Eon, I can run compute anywhere
and access that backed-up data.
We'll see in action how can
we chat with your backup
and a few words about that integration,
then we'll just see the product in action.
So integrating with the...
Eon is a storage company.
We're backing up your data.
The data sits in the cloud
and is charged in the
per gig per month model.
We want to make your data, your asset,
not just for AI but also for analytics,
both for the recovery use cases,
but also as a general data lake.
And Eon is integrated with
as a zero-ETL data utility
with any data analytics engine
that you're probably using,
and let's just see the product in action.
All right, so this is the Eon console.
And in this console,
you can first of all
start with the first view
and the first view
will show you all of
the different resources
in all of the different cloud providers
from all of the regions
and all of the service types.
And Eon does that in an agentless way.
The space of cloud infrastructure backup
was not innovated in a long, long time.
And using on-prem paradigms
of let's take my box
for my data center
and try to transform it
into a virtual appliance,
and the cloud simply doesn't work
and it doesn't work
because the cloud is built differently
than an on-prem environment.
We have so many resources,
they change all the time.
Data is moving around,
from self hosted databases
to managed databases,
SQL to NoSQL and so on.
And Eon does all of that
in an agentless way.
But what's interesting
here is that you can see
that Eon augments that view
and add automatic data classification.
So you can see what do
you have in your data.
And that is very, very important
because if I zoom in,
I can see that we've identified
in the actual resource
that I have some credit card number.
So I have financial
information in that resource
and this resource is protected.
And the reason that this
resource is protected
is because you, the customer,
have defined this example,
a very simple backup policy,
everything in production
that has financial information, or PII,
will get this backup policy,
a daily backup
for three months in one region
and a monthly for a year in another.
And this does not rely on manual tagging.
That's the big deal here.
It means that if data moves around,
the backup policy will stick.
If an application team
spins up a new application
and it's running in production
and it has financial information,
the backup policy will
be applied automatically.
So obviously, we support tags,
but giving you the ability
to define contextual backup policies
is making sure that first of all,
you're backing up everything
that you need to back up
to the right amount of time,
meeting your business needs
and compliance requirements,
but also that you're not
over backing up your data,
which can expose some
of data as a liability,
but also generate cost
that you don't want to pay.
And now let's talk about data recovery.
So this is an interesting example.
This is an RDS database.
If I wanna restore that RDS database,
I can select,
let's go back any point in time,
hit that Restore,
and with Eon,
because of the fact that we've
unlocked the actual format,
it's not stored as an RDS snapshot,
it is stored as that
immutable data lake format.
We can restore the entire
thing to any cloud provider
and any account on the fly.
So I can recover between
one cloud to another,
backup from one cloud to another.
And that's huge,
especially for events that we
need cross-cloud resilience.
But what if I'm not
after the entire thing?
I just want some of the data.
I just want to pull a few records.
If I wanna do that,
I can zoom in into our database explorer
and this is the one and
only database explorer
that runs directly on top of your backups.
So let's once again
select that point in time.
Once I hit that,
I'm locking the schema
to that point in time
and now I can run any SQL query
directly on top of my backup.
So let's pull a few records,
hit that and in a second, I have my data.
So if I want to pull a few
records out of a huge database,
I can do that live directly
on top of my backup
and think of the alternative.
The alternative can take ages
and introduce a lot of
risk pulling from the past,
once again that operating system,
end of life software and so on.
But what if I don't know where my data is?
A compliance auditor can come in
and ask, hey, for a financial
service institution,
let's show me that you
can provide evidence
of all the checks that John
Doe wrote a few years back,
or an insurance company,
I wanna see all of the rejected
claims for car insurance
and drivers in this and that age
or for the purposes of analytics,
but I don't know necessarily
where my data is.
So we've talked about AI
and we've talked about RAG.
Let's see that in action.
So with Eon,
I can search across all of my backups.
So let's do that.
Let's search for rejected
car insurance claims, so.
Once we do that,
this now runs your LLM
on top of the RAG,
that vector database
in order to search for relevant data.
So it has found the same database
that we've fetched those
insurance claims earlier on,
this RDS backup.
But what's more interesting
is that it has detected
few other databases.
So I can see here a NoSQL
database in MongoDB,
self hosted on EC2,
and then spreadsheet
that it has found on S3.
And what's interesting here
is because of the fact that
we are, as I said before,
we're doing processing of the data,
so we identify the lineage
and the join ability between
the different resources.
It has detected here that this uuid column
in that insurance policies table
correlates in the actual
values to that document
that it is found in MongoDB,
even though it has different names,
it actually found that it
had same correlation of data
and that the idea here correlates
to that rejection spreadsheet
that it has found on your S3 backups.
So this is very interesting,
and let's generate a query.
So let's ask it to build a query
and let's fetch those insurance claims
and let's group the results.
So let's see, what do I have here?
Some interesting,
so I see some age group over here.
Let's look at some car category,
and let's do that.
So the rejected claims
and let's group the results
by driver age
and car category and date.
Once I do that, this operates our agent
that does text to SQL
based on that schema.
And you see that it has generated a query.
I can see the actual
query that is generated
to run directly on top of my backups
to pull that data.
But note this,
and this is extremely important,
this new technology,
this amazing AI thing also
introduced a lot of risk.
And with Eon,
the governance and access
control sit at the storage layer.
So I can see that I'm
authorized to read that query.
Let's see why.
I'm hearing the role of a data analyst
and I've defined a contextual
access control room
that is only something
that can be done in the storage layer,
so an outside agent can't access my data.
So this is a rule that
we've defined that said,
hey, this user cannot
access any production data
that has PHI, patient health information.
So this table does not have any PHI,
I can run that query
and I have that access control.
So let's actually run the query.
Yes, please do.
And that run the query.
And I have those results,
as simple as that.
So I could search for my data
and I couldn't generate any query,
but now let's examine the actual results.
And if I look at the data,
I can see that most of
it is relatively fresh
from the past couple of months,
but this is a backup platform.
I have all of my historical data,
all of my cloud snapshots.
So let's see if I have
some data in snapshots.
This runs an AI agent
that is analyzing the previous snapshots
and it has found that
each of those resources
has some past history
and that there's some
intersection between them.
So in the past six months,
I have all of the data.
So let's generate a graph
and see how rejected claims
have looked over time.
So let's generate a graph.
Let's count the number of claims,
per month, over six months.
And now this, let's let it think,
and now generated a
graph, as simple as that,
directly on top of my backup.
I actually don't see an
interesting trend here,
but I can go on
and continue to run that
and generate graphs,
access my data.
Now think of a compliance audit
that asked me to give all the checks
that John Doe wrote five years ago,
and all I have to do is input here,
give me all the checks that
John Doe wrote five years ago
and I will immediately get the results.
And that is a whole new level
for backup and recovery,
but also unlocking that asset
not only for backup
but for the entire
organization getting a huge win
out of that as well.
I also wanna show you
what we're doing with logs
because once we started to show this
to additional customers,
they've found additional use cases
where data that was until
today kind of locked
can be used in the backup themselves.
So if we look at typical log management,
you have your access logs
and you have performance logs
and you have applicative logs and so on,
audit trail, et cetera.
And there are amazing tools out there
that are high-end tools to analyze logs.
The problem is that on one hand,
compliance requires you to
store logs for a very long time,
90 days, 180 days,
depending on the industry
and the type of data.
On the other hand, when you
actually need to analyze logs,
usually, you will only go for
the relatively fresh logs.
If I have a problem today,
I would usually analyze
logs from yesterday,
from couple days ago,
not from 80 days ago.
And those systems are extremely expensive,
and as we've said, we
want to cut down cost
and use it to things that brings us value,
and what I've been hearing from customers
is they're dumping those
retained log to S3 once again,
only keeping short, fresh logs
in their primary log analysis tools,
your seams or your performance
monitoring platform
and so on.
But when they do need
to access older logs,
when need arrives,
they need to ingest all of
it again to that system,
continue all of the retention,
a lot of manual work.
So let's see what we're doing with Eon.
Basically, those logs
from your object storage
or primary logged softwares
are ingested into that unified platform.
And we have the tools here in our console
to analyze those logs.
So if I need to access an older log,
I can just do that from here.
So let's, you know, filter those,
see that the logs in specific errors,
I can have those messages here.
I see a lot of data on
the logs themselves.
But what's really interesting here
is that I can also see
where they came from.
So I can see that these
logs were picked up
from an S3 bucket.
They can come from
multiple cloud providers.
You can pull logs from your VMs,
your database logs and so on,
access logs, obviously.
And if I wanna analyze them further,
once again, I can go into my query editor
and just fetch data from
my logs here as well.
So let's play around
with that a little bit.
So let's pull some logs,
no, no, from my AuditTrail logs
and let's order those.
Let's do that by the eventTime
and limit some results,
and I get immediate access to my logs
and I can run any query here.
So once again, if I need to find my logs,
I can do that with the
same level of performance.
And the challenge with those,
let's say high-end log systems,
they use very expensive
and great databases like Elasticsearch,
but they're very expensive.
And to hold data that you
need to retain for a long time
require just to cruise
outrageous cost actually
if you look at your Splunk
or your other tools that you're using.
And this also allows you to optimize
and shift away your budget
to things that bring you more value.
So with that, I think that I can,
let's go back to the slides
and I will pass it on
and so you can hear how SoFi
have been leveraging Eon
to get that value.
- Thanks, Ron.
- Thank you.
- So I think I need a banner up here
that says actual customer.
My goal here is I'm not a sales guy.
I'm very much an engineering leader.
I wanted to talk to you a little bit
as somebody who's gone
through this process
from engagement all the
way through implementation
in recent times,
like I think we finished
roughly three months ago
with our full deployment.
So just to talk a little
bit about the company,
SoFi is essentially a
software development company
or a tech company that owns a bank.
With that being said,
we're highly regulated as
many of you are, OCC, FRB.
We have many, many different
regulators and auditors
that we have to answer to.
Obviously, we want to move fast.
We want to enable our customers
and we want to ensure that we have uptime.
A lot of what we talk about
is how do we get to that five nines.
Most of the time, that's unrealistic.
One of the things that
led us down this path was
I had a firewall go down
in one of my Amazon environments.
The backup provider we
used was unaccessible.
We had to go through AWS
to get their EC2 backups
to actually restore that service.
This took a process of an entire day
where one of my AWS
regions was not available.
As part of that, I challenged my team,
how do we do this better?
Who can we look at? What can we do?
This isn't acceptable.
Yeah, we were available.
We have five AWS regions.
We're highly available.
We've got disaster recovery,
but I had a full region
that was unavailable,
that impacted my software developers,
that impacted my compliance team,
that impacted my cyber team.
How do we get better?
Again, some of the challenges
that Ron had spoken to,
we experienced.
We're fragmented across
five AWS regions, right?
Those backups only reside in each region.
Those snapshots only
reside in each region.
We did not have cross regional backup,
retention policies,
we're very manual, right?
My teams were having to go
create retention policies
based on that region
and what customers we were
serving out of that region.
We own a bank.
There's very, very specific
retention policies to banks.
We talked a little bit
about the firewall outage.
Anytime we had to make a change,
we were talking about days,
sometimes weeks to make a change
to whether it's the retention policy,
compliance issue that came up,
MRAs, if you guys are familiar with those,
matters requiring attention
that came up from the auditors,
like these things took weeks,
sometimes months to actually implement.
One thing, the slide is great,
but I want to talk a little bit more
about the engagement with Eon.
With Eon coming in,
it wasn't just a sales pitch.
They came in, they worked
with us from day one.
SoFi is notoriously
hard to onboard vendors.
They brought their team in
and worked with us every
single step of the way,
worked with our compliance team,
worked with our cyber team,
got everything in place
so that we could kick off our POC, right?
As part of that POC,
they walked us through
and worked with us side by side
to identify where exactly
all of our data was,
how much data we were using,
how much our AWS spend was.
Then we were actually able to
put the financials together
and be like, okay, if we go
with Eon, this is our AWS spend.
This is how much we're spending with Eon.
Now, like most of you,
I'm a little skeptical
when I see those numbers,
I think I'm pretty positive.
The number we came up with
was like a $9,000 a month savings.
I was like, that's neat.
That's great, all right.
In reality, we're plus 20% of that now.
So I think we're sitting in
about $12,000 a month of savings.
So we've blown past their estimations
and are continuing to grow, right?
So the more we grow,
the more we bring into the environment
in our five AWS regions,
the more we're actually saving.
So they're not just giving
you the sales pitch.
They're actually working
with you side by side,
identifying where the
cost saving measures are
and where these technologies
are actually helping you
implement the things that you need
and identify your issues and
how to resolve those issues.
With that, we got through the POC.
Everything was great.
We're seeing the cost savings.
We were able to, with Eon
working side by side with us,
roll out to our entire
environment across five regions
in a matter of weeks, right?
Generally, that's unheard
of for a company like ours,
probably like yours,
I mean just the software
development life cycle
takes weeks, if not
months, per region, right?
Going through SDLC, you
have lower environments,
getting up into production,
like, it's a long drawn out process.
With Eon working side by side with us,
we were able to do that for five regions
in approximately two weeks, right?
With the added benefit,
I might add, Ron talked
about this a little bit,
of the data classification,
which was a brand new thing for us
as well as my cybersecurity
team doing cartwheels
because of the ransomware protection.
I know Ron didn't talk about it a lot,
but if you bring your
cybersecurity team in,
they will be very happy
to have the conversation
around ransomware protection.
I'm positive.
We talked about the rollout,
but one of the things that I
think impressed me the most,
and he showed you the dashboard
and my manager is here
that I referenced here,
I had an unknown regulation
around student loans, right?
Obviously, SoFi is known.
We started out with student loans,
that's where we made our hay,
but there was a regulation
out of New York City
that I wasn't aware of.
We own a bank. I've got
seven-year retention policy.
As we were insourcing that infrastructure
into the corporate infrastructure,
I came across an unknown regulation
working with my compliance team
where I needed to keep all of
that student loan information,
regardless if it was SoFi
or Golden Pacific Bank,
the bank that we own,
for 10 years, right?
We had to make this change very quickly
in order to stay within compliance.
I called my manager, I
said, "I made a booboo.
We need to fix this very quickly."
Told her what we needed to do.
She literally had made the change
before I hung up the phone.
That would've taken us weeks previously.
She was able to make
the change in real time,
get us back within compliance,
be able to evidence that change
for our compliance officer
before we actually hung up the phone.
That, if nothing else,
is a testament to how
quick, easy and versatile
that the product is.
Just talking about some of the results.
I talked about the cost, right?
They underplayed the cost
savings by quite a bit
when they talk to us.
Like the cost savings is in perpetuity.
Like that is AWS spend that
I'm putting somewhere else now.
The operational burden is
almost non-existent, right?
This is all in software for us.
It all runs through our SDLC pipeline.
My team is not having to go maintain this.
We're not having this
like we build the policy,
we deploy it,
we tag the services
that need to be involved
and let it go.
I talked about the ransomware protection.
I can't talk about that nearly enough.
My cybersecurity team
is very happy with this,
and then it's a hundred
percent automated from our end,
like it is built into all of
our builds as we build them
and as we continue to move forward,
as we continue to expand,
as we will, we're in five regions now,
probably seven by the end of the year,
this is all built into our
software deployment pipeline.
What's next for us?
We're continuing to look at
how do we build these analytics
into everything that we do, right?
So that's the integration of the Eon data
that we were just speaking
about with my SRE team
that's starting to build policies
around the data
classification that we've got.
My engineering team
has started looking at,
I think, Ron, you spoke
specifically, PII and PCI data.
We own many PII and PCI environments.
We're looking at now,
how do we contextualize that
for our compliance
officer and our risk teams
to go in and be able to look at that
from an evidencing perspective.
Again, reducing the operational burden
on my engineering teams
and then again, taking
that to the next level,
and this is something that
is near and dear to my heart,
is self-service compliance,
is how do I take that, turn that evidence,
like anytime we make a change
through an MR or whatever,
how do I automate that evidence
so that my engineers don't
have to be randomized anymore.
We can just go auditor, internal
audit, one load, two load.
Here's where the repository is,
where all this data is,
or here is the query that you run.
Go get your evidence.
Again, reducing the operational burden
on my engineering teams.
All right, Ron, I'll hand
it back off to you, man.
- Yeah, thank you so much
and first of all, I want
to encourage all of you
to come over to the booth.
We have a very unique booth
where you can see additional demos,
dive into the specific use cases
that are most interesting to you.
So please, come over booth 529,
and I think that now we can
go on and have a quick Q&A,
if anyone has any questions.